foreign
welcome to another installment of Harry
Potter Theory today we're discussing
plot holes in the Prisoner of Azkaban
the Prisoner of Azkaban was one of my
favorite films in the entire Harry
Potter series and it hasn't lost an
ounce of its Sheen in the 18 years since
it debuted but even though I loved the
movie there were plenty of plot holes
and inconsistencies that popped up on
the Silver Screen So today we're going
to take a look at some of the most
interesting ones and find out why they
stand out 7. no one noticed Pettigrew if
you've seen Harry Potter and the
Prisoner of Azkaban then I'm sure you're
aware of the massive role that Peter
Pettigrew plays in it the entire film
centers are under single premise that
Sirius Black was responsible for the
murder of Harry Potter's parents but
during the main reveal we discovered
that black wasn't the one who betrayed
James in the liposa in fact it was
another one of their school day friends
Othello Marauder named Peter Pettigrew
but there's a problem with that if Harry
Hermione Ron or the Weasley twins had
taken a moment to pay attention to the
Marauders map wouldn't they have noticed
the strange man's name that always
seemed to accompany them whenever they
were slinking around Hogwarts late at
night they would have expected to only
see their own names on the map but what
about Peter Pettigrew wouldn't his name
have appeared right alongside Ron and
what about when Ron was sleeping
wouldn't the appearance of Peter
pettigrew's name have been an even
larger cause for concern even though the
children noticed Peter's name on the map
they certainly didn't seem to be overly
alarmed 6. Time Turner rules now when we
talk about plot holes in the Prisoner of
Azkaban the time Turners present more
than their fair share before starters it
doesn't really make too much sense to
allow a 13 year old girl access to time
travel even if Hermione was the most
trustworthy student at Hogwarts why
would Professor Minerva McGonagall
entrust her with such a dangerous device
not only could she have destroyed the
future she could have harmed herself
time travel was tricky as Lord Voldemort
and Harry Potter's own children
demonstrated decades later which brings
me to my next Point why weren't time
Turners used more often in later years
JK Rowling carefully explained just how
impractical a time turn would be for
preventing loved ones from dying after
all with time travel established in The
Wizarding World it wouldn't really make
sense for the likes of Dumbledore to not
use it especially when traveling back in
time would have saved the world from so
many of Voldemort's atrocities during
the events of the Prisoner of Azkaban
every time Turner in Britain had been
Charmed with the special spell so that
its users could only ever stay in the
past for at most five hours but by the
time Albus Severus Potter enrolled at
Hogwarts the rules for time turn has
changed a new batch of devices had been
created and one of them provided
unbridled travel to and from the past
when we try to wonder why the ministry
of magic and the staff at Hogwarts never
use time travel more frequently the only
obvious answer we can find is that it
was simply too dangerous but that raises
another question number five why didn't
Voldemort try to get a Time Turner why
didn't Voldemort ever try to get his
hands on a Time Turner even if he only
used the devices that the ministry of
magic controlled which didn't allow free
travel through time the dark wizard
could have accomplished far more than he
did during the seven years Harry
attended Hogwarts and when you think
about it you have to wonder why
Voldemort never tried his hand at
creating a true Time Turner like the one
that Draco Malfoy used when he saved his
son Scorpius and Albus Potter from the
past Voldemort was the most powerful
dark wizard in recorded history he was
perhaps even greater than her but the
foul the infamous sorcerer who first
bred basilisks a and when he tore his
soul into seven parts and created his or
cruxes Voldemort demonstrated that there
was no aspect of magic to Taboo for him
to utilize so if a teenage girl like
Hermione was able to achieve so much
with the time Turner why didn't Lord
Voldemort ever employed them if his
Death Eaters had only one of the time
Turners in their possession the night
their Master first died while failing to
kill an infant Harry Potter they could
have quickly brought him back to life
4. Harry used magic outside of school
several times throughout the film series
Harry Potter flinched at the idea of
using magic outside of Hogwarts he was
underage and Performing magic was always
a risky Affair the ministry would
quickly track him down and Harry was
starting to get the feeling that
Cornelius fudge's subordinates weren't
too happy with his troublemaking ways
even when Harry was older there were
times when he hesitated to use magic
outside of the school but during the
Prisoner of Azkaban Harry used a small
charm lumos maxima while practicing
sorcery in his bedroom even though it
was a relatively small display of magic
and nothing that would risk exposing
himself to Muggles the ministry could
have punished him and Harry should have
been well aware of that but he didn't
seem to care as he practiced the
incantation under the safety of his bed
sheets 3. Mrs Norris's yellow eyes Argus
Felch was the resident caretaker for
Hogwarts School of Witchcraft and was a
dream he he was Infamous for more than a
few bizarre personality traits but
students knew him best for the strange
relationship he shared with his pets Mrs
Norris the brown cat was more than just
a critter that Felch fed and bathed
although Dumbledore treated Argus with
respect there was no debate surrounding
the sad fate that Phil suffered he was a
squib The Offspring of magical parents
Who Bore no magical ability of his own
and due to that he was never able to
climb to the rigid hierarchy of
Wizarding Society instead of learning
the ins and outs of potion making and
launching a successful career as a hair
loss elixirest or a major zoologist
filge only served the magical class and
As a caretaker that meant cleaning up
the messes that all the young Wizards
and witchers around Hogwarts made and
Mrs Norris his only companion was always
Faithfully at his side but if you pay
close attention to Mrs Norris in the
prisoner of Ben you'll notice something
her eye color changes now this feline's
eyes would change in later films as well
but in the Prisoner of Azkaban if you
focus you can see that they Flash from
yellow in one scene back to Red 2. open
sesame do you know how to open the
Marauders map well you might since
you've already seen the films and read
the books but imagine that you just
happened across the Relic and had no
clue how to reveal its secrets of all
the possible passwords and incantations
How likely would it be that your mind
would suddenly think of I solemnly swear
that I am up to no good because that's
essentially what the Weasley twins did
when they discovered the secrets of the
Marauders map the map's creators James
Potter Peter Pettigrew Sirius Black and
Remus Lupine never passed the secret on
to Ron Weasley's older brothers and
there weren't very many hints stashed
around Hogwarts in fact when JK Rowling
was asked how the Weasley boys knew how
to open the map Trump she herself could
hardly answer in a quick moment of
conjecture she imagined that the boys
simply thought of the phrase all on
their own but considering all the
possible passwords that's a trillion to
one scenario the only possible way that
the twins could have learned the magical
incantation was through plot hole magic
and sanazan is to say 1. how did Sirius
afford presence Zuri's back was a
convicted murderer by the time he
escaped Azkaban every Wizard and wedge
knew exactly what black went to jail for
and the posters that adhered to every
wall and building would help remind them
just in case they forgot Zoe with so
much heat on his Trail how did Sirius
manage to buy Harry Potter a brand new
broomstick the ministry of magic and
their auras would have staked out every
known black Family holding there'd be no
secret Castle or Diagon Alley apartment
where black can hide retrieve a few gold
galleons and continue on his journey to
Redemption so how exactly did he get
money and how exactly did he buy Harry's
gifts and they have it seven plot holes
from Harry Potter and the Prisoner of
Azkaban the film what did you think do
you know any plot holes that didn't end
up on this list share them in the
comments below and if you have your own
head Cannon for why some of these plot
holes make sense be sure to share your
reasons as well until next time remember
it does not do to dwell on dreams and
forget to live
foreign